deux objectifs 1 08 au derrière lequel
nous sommes tous rassemblés s'est créée
en octobre dernier alors que le récif
avait urgence et le prince en haïti avis
vous a précédé deux roues durant
mais les difficultés sont des intérieurs
depuis le début des années 2000 les
choix de politiques qui ont été faits
ont considérablement modifié
l'organisation et le financement de la
vie publique
enfin la situation et des depuis
longtemps à la relance elle est
aujourd'hui dramatique si les patients
restent le plus souvent soignés dans des
conditions dignes
c'est au détriment de soignants qui
s'use trop vite les épuise
inexorablement les conditions d'exercice
des feignants au sein de la public sont
si mauvaises qu'elles aient poste de
vacances s'accumulent parfois plus
personne ne veut de ces métiers mal
payés aux cadences infernales
parce que seule la rentabilité des
séjours contre la tutelle administrative
le mans compte personnel non humains et
c'est cette perte d'humanité qui peuvent
à l'hôpital parce que sans personnel
il n'y a pas d'hôpital psychiatrique
ouzou avait levé des structures en
cumulé la tarification à l'activité
le financement délibérément ou douces ou
des charges réelles l'austérité des
méthodes de management l'extraction
progressive des soignants de la
gouvernance hospitalière
parce que les déstructurant donc nous
pensons que le tel public n'est plus à
même de remplir ses missions si la
politique comptable qui prévaut
aujourd'hui ne base pas à pas les
politiques de santé consiste en une
analyse du besoin
les difficultés sociales des habitants
dans le département aggraver une
situation pour dire l ordre d'idée en
pologne en slovaquie en slovénie
les arrières merci murray numéro 4 en
notre direction plus nos missions
administratives à partir du 31 janvier
2001 par cet acte symbolique une semaine
chez son notre désaccord avec la
politique d'austérité qui a compilé
depuis dix ans dans les hôpitaux publics
et tous nos directions à une gestion
comptable des ressources humaines les
exclusions notre désarroi face à la
désertion d'une autre établissement
parce qu'il part de spécialité et nous
nous opposons farouchement au système de
la tarification à l'activité qui a
compté à la sélection d' actes rentables
dans les établissements privés aux
dépens des hôpitaux publics qui sera le
tous les patients
quelle que soit la pathologie quel que
soit leur âge et quelle que soit leur
situation sociale pour illustrer notre
inquiétude
voici quelques exemples concrets de ce
qui se passe dans notre établissement
dans le service des urgences après
qu'une tenue de véritables combats aux
costumes services continuent à
fonctionner pendant que mal dans des
locaux vétustes est sous-dimensionné
avec 72 me par an pour les quarante
sonde autorisées et avec 50% de poste de
virginie pour 12 tpa pouvoir sur 24 la
chef de service vient de remettre sa
démission définitive à la direction la
compétition salariale avec l'intérim et
le privé ne permet plus d'être attractif
pour des urgences vient régulièrement
deux mois l'été dernier deux semaines en
fin d'année faute de personnel médical
paramédical ce qui désorganise hôpital
accroît la charge de soins dans les
services
mal aimée régulière sont des patients
dans le service de pédiatrie à fermer 40
% de ses 14 sur 30 90 en fin d'année
faute de personnel paramédical au pic
des épidémies hivernales et se sont
fermées depuis 2006 en plein air ont
quitté le service entre mars et juin et
19 ans les autres produits sont peut
être difficile les effectifs ne sont pas
adaptés à la charge de travail
ainsi au moins d'essence ont été
contraints de transférer des enfants
désistement une prise en charge les
animateurs dans d'autres hôpitaux et
parfois très éloignés faute de place à
part en écologie deux tiers des postes
de praticiens hospitaliers ne sont pas
un quart délicate sur cette super niveau
des personnages aussi depuis plus d'un
an
trois supplémentaires ont été fermés en
fin d'année du visuel est donc l'un
fissures 16 seulement qu'ils étaient
disponibles en accès avec des carcasses
est bon dans des services pendant des
mois et des mois
lorsque l'hôpital n'aurait pu faire face
une direction et neuf plus d'en face se
sera vu dans la réalité par des
mouvements qui sont d'études ils sont
complètement dégradé les patients qui
ont des musiques assez évident dans des
conditions qui seraient impossibles dans
d'autres pays membres de personnel on ne
plus accompagner les patients
l'extérieur autrefois des talents palier
préparation digne où aller chercher de
l'argent leur part les courses pour
retourner à la maison sont les passants
qui sont très fragiles des conditions de
travail selon plastique et de mes
salaires des soignants sûrement la scène
point bas et le gouvernement va être
inflexible avec des mesures héritées des
besoins aux réalités on va dormir je
dirais qu'il arrange bien possible qui
serait depuis fort longtemps
sans ces deux gouvernorats viennent
poursuit cette politique de
privatisation qui réserve au tibet 7e
rang parmi les traditions appauvrissant
temps sinon en voir davantage de secteur
public hospitalier
doit-on a levé le c'est un privilège
accessible qu'à une partie des patients
précaires
doit-on rappeler qu'à saint denis la
mise en fonction des personnes qui
présentent en urgence par l'ouverture
sociale je ne prendrai qu'un seul
exemple et par des sentiments de
néophytes qui a déjà rencontré glissé
paravents en neige cette distance qui
mixe entre la cité et dans l'ancien
docteur de l'hôpital public et nous
sommes finalement des collègues de
travail et qui fait une saint jean de
justement de le réduire ces existences
pour poser des questions et avoir une
réponse à une question le sentiment que
l'on a eu globalement ce que j'ai pas
vous refaire toute la science qui a
clôturé depuis 2 arrive c'est quand on a
eu l'impression qu'elle n'a pas les
mains libres et qu'elle n'avait pas les
moyens de répondre à tous les ans des je
pense que ces décisions là elles sont
très budgétaire et finalement
est-ce que mal à buzeins est en mesure
de nous apporter une réponse vraie
solution plus tôt je ne sais pas si la
vie sans qu'on s'est posée à la fin de
cet entretien